>> What companies, governments, countries
individuals can do to make the world a better
place - is be honest. That's the first step
- to actually be honest. It's fine to make
commitments, it's fine to make pledges, it's
fine to say we'll do this and that, but unless
it's actually executed - unless the promise
is made real, then it, it's kind of pointless.
I mean it's very easy to make pledges - it's
very easy to, to say we'll do this and that
and never do it. But ideally, I'd like people
to be honest - and I think that works from
governments and corporations up, down to the
individual. If people say I'm going to do
something positive - and it could be something
really simple, like you know - be more environmentally
conscious. Or, uh for governments to say actually
if we say we're going to do this, we go ahead
and execute it and make sure there is some
sort of follow-up. Uh, I think the time for
empty promises is gone and people should focus
on honesty.